there are many ways that we use color
artists use different colors to express
emotions marketers attach colors to
their brands to make them more
recognizable animals use colors to ward
off predators or attract mates and
people do too what is color scientists
define color as the limited range of
light that we humans could see we
classify different types of light based
on their wavelength which can be
anywhere from many meters in between
each wave peak to lengths as short as
the diameter of an atom the full
electromagnetic spectrum ranges from
high-energy light waves with short
wavelengths by cosmic and gamma rays to
low energy light waves with long
wavelengths like radio waves the light
we are able to see called the visible
light spectrum ranges from violet light
which has a wavelength of about 400
nanometers
to red light which has a longer
wavelength of about 650 to 700
nanometers but how do we perceive the
visible light spectrum when light
bounces off an object like this painting
into our eyes it first hits the cornea a
film that lays on top of our eyes this
layer bends light towards the pupil
which dilates our contracts to let in
more or less light once light passes
through the pupil it is sent to the lens
which angles and focuses the light to a
point on the outer layer of the retina
here light-sensitive cells called rods
and cones send information to ganglion
nerve cells in the inner retina ganglion
cells then send the information to the
optic nerve which sends the signal to
the brain where the signal is processed
and interpreted rods and cones the two
types of light-sensitive cells located
on the outer retina have different jobs
rods are responsible for our perception
of light and dark and our peripheral
vision cones are what allow us to see
color they are found in the center of
the retina where light is focused
pones come in three varieties each
sensitive to a different range of light
interestingly we have more cones
sensitive to red light meaning our
vision is best for warmer colors like
reds oranges and yellows
however our cones aren't sensitive to
light with wavelengths shorter than 400
nanometers or longer than around 700
nanometers for example a gamma waves
wavelength is about the size of an
atomic nucleus which is much too short
for any of our three types of cones to
sense radio waves are too long with
wavelengths longer than two Empire State
buildings put together that doesn't mean
that these forms of light aren't visible
per se other animals have different
kinds and numbers of cones which allows
them to see the world differently than
we do dogs for example are more limited
in the wavelength vacancy because they
only have two types of cones leaving
them colorblind two differences between
red and green butterflies have four
types of cones in their eyes letting
them see ultraviolet light the animal
with the best color vision might be the
mantis shrimp which has 12 different
kinds of cones if Pablo Picasso and Paul
Klee created amazing works of art with
just three types of cones imagine the
masterpieces the mantis shrimp would
create with 12
you